cher journal bon ben ça y est c'est
officiel je suis vieille pourtant je me
suis éduqué je me suis informé mais je
comprends bien que faire la démarche de
se mettre à jour c'est déjà être dépassé
je refuse d'être mon père qui imitent
les rappeurs en faisant yoyo avec les
doigts je refuse d'être ma mère qui ne
comprend rien aux réseaux sociaux
oui juste et pourtant
bah je n'ai rien compris à ce match at
et je suis de celles pour qui tik tok ce
n'est rien d'autre que le bruit du temps
qui passe et qui me rappelle que je suis
bien trop vieille pour ces conneries je
suis devenu mon père et ma mère à la
fois quand je fronce les sourcils en
écoutant les jeunes musiciens inventaire
une syntaxe
quand j'utilise mal une nouvelle
expression qui paraît-il ne se dit déjà
plus depuis deux ans mais ça excusez moi
comment est ce que je peux le débit
n'est pas je réalise que mon enfance et
si lointaine que la mode de l'époque est
déjà redevenu à la mode quand on me dit
ok boomer alors que l'espèce deux seuls
petits combats ce terme fait référence
aux personnes nées entre 45 et 65 est ce
que j'ai vraiment l'air d'être né dans
ces années là franchement
excuse moi de te le dire mais je n'ai
grandi que dans les années 90 tu vois et
contrairement à toi sombre ignares que
tu est moi j'ai lu des livres avec des
vraies pages puisque c'est une page j'ai
écrit des lettres à la main tu m'entends
à la main nous on ne se faisait pas de
lamu l'âge dans les tentes jambes sur
les réseaux on a connu les forfaits
limités
on a connu les vhs qu'on louait que la
personne d'avant il n'avait même pas
rembobinez nous pour écrire coucou en
textos et ben on devait taper 3 x 2 2 x
6 3 x 8 et le tout multiplié par deux
nous on a connu la guerre nous le caire
compte sur les cheveux cassants et les
pointes sèches un an pus tôt comme ça
c'est autre chose
voilà ça y est je mélange tout ça doit
être la sénilité qui me gagne tu es le
début de la fin quoi ok boomer n'importe
quoi espèce de petit con vas retourne
forte live sur switch là il rate de
m'emmerder